uh las vegas has a lot of good buffets
i've heard this
i mean you'll pay like a hundred but
isn't it like mainly buffets it's all
buffets really yeah like i would i stay
because you know aukey's from vegas
right so like literally every third day
is a buffet and after a while i'm just
like bruh i can we have like something
else just like a single meal i get it
though because you're just gonna sit
there and gamble all night so yeah it
doesn't matter if you like just stuff
yourself yeah well if you're like if you
feel like yeah if you've been like
walking around on the strip all day yeah
and you have enough room then yeah of
course buffet's fantastic but you know
if i'm like [ __ ]
lazily sitting around in a house and
then some sometimes aki's mom's like
let's go to a buffet i'm like no please
no no i can't they have no time limit
you could be there all day kind of
actually some of them look amazing as
well i think i saw some youtube videos
of them and it's like michelin star
chefs or something yeah we've we've been
to all of them and some of them are
[ __ ] amazing but it's also like a
buffet bus tour
no i haven't takes you around to all the
buffets no i haven't i i know a friend
who why would you want to have a pass
that takes you on the same
that sounds horrible when i start eating
i don't want to stop until i'm done yeah
and then when i'm done i stop yeah yeah
yeah because the worst thing is when you
are like times for my meal yeah and the
worst thing is if you get on the bus
you're going yeah if you start a meal
and you're not totally full but then
you'd stop yeah you stop anyway because
you've got to leave or you've got to do
something else and then you kind of
become full but not the satisfying yeah
you're just like it's like the bloated
floor right yeah yeah
yeah and that's that sounds like an
awful experience yeah if you had to do
that on the same day on the bus fun for
like college
student aged people i think there is
i mean i still do love buffets it's just
there's a time and a place for it i
can't have it every day i can't have it
right wait how do you rate buffets then
because there's so many different types
i can't rape a face i didn't do google
reviews back when i was eating if you
had what about japan buffets have you
had the buffets here yeah i've had i
took you guys i think yeah only conor
karnt did we went to
it's a hot pot buffet oh that doesn't
matter oh that's that is about that
to me it's not a buffet if you have to
ask the guy to come over and then you
order more stuff yeah but then you go
over to the vegetable section you get
your own vegetables
yeah
yeah i'd say because buffet to me is
truly like everything is you can go up
and get it yeah yeah yeah so i feel like
when there's a block of you have to call
someone over and be like can i have more
meat
that's how you get the fresh one
but you can also like go up to like the
chef at the buffet and be like can you
give me the fresher one depending at the
buffet i know las vegas yeah vegas you
can do it there's some really weird
buffets in japan though i went to one um
like the sweet spot
buffet park didn't you it's like an
american chain or something american
chain here it's apparently supposed to
be an american dining chain
sizzler
sizzler in japan has like the famous
salad buffet yeah and it was the most
sizzlers in japan yeah
and it was like the i think i went to
one in tokyo stadium or udabashi stadium
the one that ibashi
the massive stadium the park tokyo dome
tokyo dome that's it yeah there's there
was one in there there was a sizzler or
some form of chain and i went
i didn't know it wasn't bubblegums i
went to it and i was like all right
what's going to be on the buffet it was
the weirdest selection of stuff you can
imagine right he was like the dessert
was like first in the buffet as well so
it's like ice cream
and like french toast but this was like
5 p.m between first in the buffet like
when you get your tray and stuff the
dessert was there first oh weird and
then i was like okay and then next to it
is like
self-service taco station
but there was no salsa or guac so it was
just like beef this is the beef wrapped
up
and uh the tortilla yeah
both of those mexicans crying yeah
it was just beet it was just beef it was
just beef and the tortilla yeah there
you go
okay
yeah this makes sense next up it's like
pasta like italian pasta and it was like
i don't know what this pasta was it
didn't taste like anything it tastes
like a weird arabiata yeah it was really
strange and then in the middle there was
like a bunch of salad but the salad was
strange as well there was like barely
any lettuce there was like chopped
oranges
um like a bunch of croutons and stuff i
was like what is this in the hotel
uh yeah next to it oh the hotel buffet
no it wasn't a part of the hotel it was
like a but the tokyo hotel also has
buffets yeah it was so confusing and it
was just the weirdest i've never seen a
buffet like it and half the stuff was
terrible
and they didn't have a coffee machine or
anything it was water oh it was just
water peasants instant sauce
and if you wanted the soft drink you to
order it
that's actually normal in a lot of
buffets waters in england as well
because that's how they make the money
because that's you have to pay for this
we pay for the drinks in the uk some
buffet places a lot of buffet places the
drinks i thought they were alcoholic
drinks oh no they charge for like normal
drinks as well and that's that's how
that's like the secret of how they make
the money right because you have to
order the drinks separately but the food
is like all you can eat right right
right so i mean i mean that's that's
more standard how much are buffets in
the uk well we can you can like depend
if tanner is like standard you can go
like pretty high end and get like 20
pounds 25 really in the south it's like
20 to 30. oh [ __ ] really yeah it's not
it's like a tanner oh my gosh no i was
like up north oh my god
that's so cheap the buffets were
around where i was i think they were
like never more than twenty and twenty
was like premium you're like
produce in your area you can't you can't
eat out in the south like less than 15
quid like 15 quids like the cheapest
cheaper cheaper you would go
you could go to any restaurant and get a
main for like 10 pounds
like in like a fresh maine that's
prepared well so why would you go to
your buffet and stuff yourself full of
chips and rice
and pay 15 quid
fair enough
buffets are just fun for family i think
all things yeah yeah because you can
challenge people you should get your kid
to shut up and run away right challenge
people what do you what do you challenge
people like who may help who can conquer
it first
pretend you're matt stoney
is that fun you should do that as a
teenager you only eat one plate yeah
i did think it was really cool and there
was an all you can eat buffet one time
and uh for pizza did you wear buffet
pants
what
there's an eat buffet pizza chain here
in japan as well yeah called shakies oh
it's americans yeah that's amazing
can we go back can we go back to the
buffet pants what the [ __ ] is a buffet i
didn't even hear that
she said buffet yeah she was like do you
worry about that so you can put the
elastic band over your stomach when
you're done eating that sounds like the
most american inventor like invention
i've ever heard
[Music]
are you serious it's real
well in my friend group
did other friend groups do this as well
i don't know was this like a just your
friend group type of thing no it's like
more than
20 people how much does a buffet cost in
san francisco
an arm and a leg
that this was like eight years ago
though so it's only got a dawn now
eight years ago well i mean yeah that's
how much vegas buffets are they're like
40 50 bucks oh they're worth it i don't
think they don't eat they don't taste
good the high the high end ones though
where you pay a little extra like 80 90
dollars is like worth 80 90 dollars
what like that did you get like sirloin
steak on demand uh yeah
in my opinion maybe about half the time
not worth it yeah i mean i mean two
grand and then spend 90 on the stage
yeah yeah i mean that's just like sounds
like alien to me because like in the uk
i don't think that kind of buffet exists
buffets exist as like a cheap food a
cheap alternative to eating a lot of
food if you just want to order a lot of
food each time eat a [ __ ] ton of food
they don't really care about the quality
are there a lot of indian uh curry
buffets because in sf certain areas
pretty much every buffet in the uk has
indian curry units i'm gonna be honest
they're pretty bad though they're really
[ __ ] bad i mean i i would argue that
pretty like night actually i don't think
i've ever been to a good a good buffet
place in the uk in terms of like this is
good food you go there to eat a [ __ ] ton
of food and you trick your brain into
thinking it tastes good because you're
eating so much food but in reality it
just tastes like [ __ ]
right i think that's
like the whole plate situation with
buffets you know because when you get a
dish right that you've hand selected
it's normally perfectly fit for that
plate you know when you start going
around the buffet and you start putting
things on i don't want some of the foods
touching yeah
and like i hate that because i'm like
well you know i don't want um this saucy
dish to touch the thing that's supposed
to be like dry yeah so it's like it's
kind of a mess
but if there is sauce it's like all
right if this dish has a lot of sauce
how do i how do i kind of like integrate
this with my other food
on my plate i honestly never cared
because i'm like at the end of the day
this is all going to turn into [ __ ] so
it doesn't matter
oh so it's all going on
[Music]
i'm like other buffet who has like
[ __ ] three different plates right
because you can't like something you
can't mix i take the plate i go and get
another plate to like make sure the
dishes are right you don't get the food
put it down eat it and then go again no
no no no no no because that's too much
effort what if you change your mind
though after you eat the first place
away
it's all gonna get thrown out anyway
what if you take cause sometimes i've
taken too much of something starchy and
i've been like [ __ ] i can't eat this
this is this is prime real estate in my
stomach i can't have another bread roll
it's just cheap because in vegas i never
get bread
because in vegas apparently it's a law
now that all the buffet places at the
end of every day they have to throw out
like everything
because there was this lawsuit that dead
ass i read about this there was this
lawsuit that happened a couple of years
ago where they kept some of the food and
like stored it in like the behind like
the store
and some homeless guy came up ate it got
food poisoning sued the buffet place and
what well hopefully you got a nice home
yeah what yeah what and so now
yeah
and now in vegas i don't know about the
whole state of nevada but in vegas every
buffet place legally has to throw out
every single food that's left on that
day and make it fresh the next day so i
can't imagine how much that's good for
customers though but unfortunately
terrible for it's also a waste of a
shitload of food you'd wish they just
gave it away but it's logistically it's
quite hard to get away a lot of food
like donate it to the shelter yeah yeah
there's some i think some coffee chains
in the uk uh especially london i think
like prep does it where like at the end
of the day someone will come in get all
the sandwiches they didn't sell and then
just at that night go and take them to
homeless people yeah yeah so they're
still like good to eat yeah that makes
more sense